hey what is up guys i'm kim Bhd here and
the new Nexus family has been announced
today everything is official now so the
rumors can finally stop so this is a
video where I'm gonna go over all my
thoughts on it the Nexus 6 the Nexus 9
the other stuff that was announced and
gave all my thoughts on the official
stuff as well as the other things that
have been uncovered in twitter and
google+ and other places i've found so
you got some extra information here so
this is the video to share with
everything we know about the new Nexus
is and what we need to know let's just
get right into it so first of all
Android 5.0 is now a thing and it's
completely finished now so it's going to
be rolled out to nexuses and Google Play
edition devices over the coming weeks so
I have a Nexus 5 I have a Google Play
edition HTC One m8 if you have these
devices to or a nexus 10 or a Nexus 7
these will get updated to Android 5.0 we
saw the Developer Preview before but
I've mentioned before that's not really
complete that wasn't the complete final
operating system so now in the final one
we're gonna get a couple of new features
we're gonna get this battery saver mode
that'll extend the life of our device
and the last few percent by up to 90
minutes which is great we get multiple
account support before we can only have
that on tablets but now you can have say
a guest profile on your phone too and
there's also now smart lock which is
introduced to basically have trusted
Bluetooth devices be able to unlock your
phone and not require a password
whenever they're connected so you get
all the material design stuff you'll get
all of the animations we talked about
when I showed the Developer Preview and
also 5.0 is Android L lollipop in case
you were caring about the codename but
that's not the most exciting thing that
was mentioned today of course the most
exciting part is a new hardware that's
come out to run these new operating
systems so let's take a look at the
Nexus 9 the Nexus 9 is an 8.9 inch
display tablet that's replacing both the
Nexus 10 and the Nexus 7 so this is sort
of an in-between tablet it's made by HTC
and it's beautiful the specs are pretty
solid the 8.9 inch display is a 2048 by
1536 resolution it has 2 gigs of RAM and
a dual core and Vidia k1 chip at 2.3
gigahertz 16 or 32gb of storage an 8
megapixel camera and a six thousand
seven hundred million power battery now
those Nvidia k1 chip is 64 bit ready so
is paired with two gigs of RAM but of
course it can handle a lot more and the
fact that it's going to be running stock
Android 5.0
is probably going to perform really well
I haven't seen a whole bunch of other
devices with the NVIDIA k1 chip except
for the shield tablet that I reviewed
not too long ago but I mentioned in that
video that it was a really seriously
good performer and it also rammed pretty
close to stock Android honestly the
Nexus 9 it looks like the most
impressive Android tablet I've ever seen
it has this brush metal sides it has
those massive boom sound speakers thank
goodness HTC kept with that and it has a
couple of other HTC features like
built-in so you can double tap the
screen to wake it little things like
that will be moved over but it's a very
impressive looking piece of hardware
with all the metal on it and the sleek
looks so even though it's a four by
three aspect ratio I'm okay with it
replacing the Nexus 10 because it has
the front-facing speakers that the Nexus
10 has probably even better it also has
a keyboard case a first-party keyboard
case made from Google and that's really
important because I use the Nexus 10
standing up so I can look at it and
watch videos and stuff all the time so
having a case that'll prop it up and
having a keyboard on it is really nice
I'll get to the price of that in the
description or right below the like
button but the price of the tablet will
be starting at 16 gigs $399 for Wi-Fi
only there's also an LTE model too that
will be up for pre-order on October 17th
I'm excited to get my hands on it just
because it's replacing the Nexus 10 I've
been used for so long and also because
Android 5.0 lollipop is pretty tempting
to me now secondly let's talk about the
Nexus 6 I did a wishlist video on this
guy right it's a Moto X blown up so what
we're seeing now is its official a 6.0
inch quad HD AMOLED display it's a big
phone and essentially you're gonna get a
lot of the things that we predicted
about this new Nexus One looking at the
Moto X the design hasn't changed all
that much it's gonna look very familiar
if you've seen it and you might even now
be able to call the Moto X as sort of a
nexus 6 mini with Motorola features the
specs of the thing look baller
absolutely boss it has a Snapdragon 805
chip it has three gigabytes of RAM has
the audrina 420 GPU it's a
top-of-the-line device clearly and a lot
of the things that we'll talk about
later reflect that and a lot of people's
immediate reaction to seeing six inch
phone is well that's way too big to be a
phone I really wish it was smaller and
at first I think this too but I want to
feel it in the hand because I looked up
the measurement the vertical measurement
of the iPhone
six plus is 159 millimeters and the
vertical measurement of the much larger
screened Nexus 6 is 159 millimeters so
this is a very similar size in the hand
to the Nexus 6 and I'll look for other
reference devices for perspective and
when I get my hands on and I'll be doing
a video to share with you guys exactly
how big it is in the hand but I'm
curious to see how it feels it's also a
very thick phone it's ten and a half
millimeters thick
but that also gives the advantage of a
couple things one a 3200 milliamp hour
battery and 2 a 13 megapixel camera with
optical image stabilization it doesn't
have the dimple on the back like the
Nexus 6 does but it has that same ring
camera flash and because it's made by
Motorola it makes me think it has very
similar camera optics which does concern
me cameras have never been a high point
on nexuses image processing in general
has never been a high point on Android
devices but they've worked on this and
because it's stock Android it will
likely be a little bit different so
we'll see how the camera performs
fingers crossed it's better than the
Moto X and better than other previous
Nexus is but that wouldn't really be
saying much I am particularly happy
about the specs and a combination of
things that make this a really premium
device it has a massive battery and
really high-end specs which makes me
think even though it's a quad HD display
stock Android 5.0 lollipop on this
device will probably last a long time
and perform really well it also has a
couple of the extra features we talked
about from Android 5.0 so it has that
battery saving mode it has a turbo
charging technology which means you'll
be able to put it on the charger for
about 15 minutes and get six hours of
charge out of it
I will be testing that and overall it
looks to be built like a tank just like
the Moto X was kind of hard to bend the
thing when it's completely made of metal
around the ring and it seems like a
pretty impressive chunk of a phone to
hold in your hand now here's where it
gets a little bit different the final
price will be 649 dollars starting off
contract what all the previous Nexus is
have typically been a lower end price
the latest one being $350 and you can
still buy the Nexus 5 for $350 off
contract but when you think about it
this is actually not that crazy of a
price for the Nexus think about this
again it has the audrina 420 GPU it has
the Snapdragon 805 chip three gigabytes
of RAM
a huge beautiful quad HD 6 inch AMOLED
display a massive build a 3200 milliamp
hour battery when you put all that into
perspective all these specs $649 is not
that bad the iPhone 6 plus is nine
hundred and forty nine dollars off
contract so I'm not gonna go ahead and
say this Nexus 6 is overpriced yeah it's
way more than the previous Nexus is but
this is sort of the beginning of a march
of well we talked about Android silver
it's a more premium feeling stock
Android experience it's a reference
device that's not necessarily cheap
because other people are gonna be able
to buy it too it's gonna be sold in
carrier stores AT&T Sprint t-mobile US
Cellular and Verizon will all be able to
sell the Nexus 6 okay I'm excited to
feel this device in the hand I want to
see how big it feels 10 millimeters
thick I think is actually more important
than 6 inch screen but will feel it will
not bend it but will twist it and see if
it holds up to durability so that
actually goes on pre-order on October
29th at the end and the Nexus 9 I don't
know if I mentioned goes on sale
pre-order on October 17 there was one
other little thing announced it's called
the Nexus player it's part of the Nexus
family technically but it's very similar
to Google chromecast it's essentially an
Android TV based media player slash
gaming console it's the first ever
device with this Android TV operating
system and that makes me think that that
is the biggest difference between it and
chromecast so you'll have a full-fledged
operating system to play Android games
to web browsers and to play with a
controller and do all sorts of things
that you wouldn't be able to do with
chromecast I want to test that out I'm
gonna be plugging it into my TV and
figuring out exactly what the
differences are to see if it's worth
your money so stay tuned for that video
but until then just know that it's a
sort of a chromecast Plus so there you
have it it's the new Nexus family I'm
very excited to get my hands on these
things and replace the Nexus 7 in Nexus
10 I have with the Nexus 9 and to get my
hands on this stock Android 5.0 lollipop
final version if you follow me on
twitter you'll know that I've tweeted a
whole bunch more information I'm gonna
be sharing stuff along the way when my
device ships and want to get my hands on
it am i doing unboxing if you guys care
but definitely leave a thumbs up if you
enjoyed this video and share it with the
people who are interested
any announcements today from Google so
thank you for watching if you enjoyed
hit that subscribe button because there
are more videos like this on the way and
you can be the first to see em and I'll
talk to you guys in the next video peace